It may be a good feeling to lie down without bothering to do any work ... sometimes it is more than good! Whether
This relaxation to avoid work or evade physical activity, we all passed these days. But why some
People more lazy than others? Is there a "couch potato" gene?
Evolution is the shape of our brain and body so that we respond positively to the stimuli of nature, such as
Food, sex, and even exercise. Wait - exercises ?? Yes, the fun we feel is coming a lot
Of the dopamine system in our brain, which transmits this message through our body
And in turn helps to ensure that our sex remains. For many, the fun resulting from
Exercise can be as addictive as food and sex. But while we want more
Food and sex, many struggle for physical exercise, though
It is an important part of human vitality
Scientists studying mice have found an interesting gene to do with this. After dividing the mice
For two groups - a group chose to run on the wheel more, and the group that chose to run for less -
The difference was evident in their descendants. After 10 generations,
The number of races that preferred jogging continued to run by 75% more than the second group
16 generation was running 7 miles per day compared to 4 miles the rate of other rats ran
Their motivation for physical activity seems to come from genes.
We all inherit our genes from our parents and play an important role in the development of our brain
These genes may make some people literally yearn for activity. In fact the brain
Of the mice running had a larger dopamine system and areas that treated the stimulus
And awards. They need exercise and only their brain will behave in a way similar to the symptoms of drug addiction
Which appears in mice that have been cocaine addicts and have been deprived of cocaine. Yes they are genetically addicted to jogging
We also inherit genes responsible for our other traits - from impulsiveness, to procrastination
And work ethics down to laziness. It turns out that our physical laziness has
It is due to the gene of "couch potatoes" - or any deformation in a natural gene that regulates the level of our activity.
This gene is responsible for the type of dopamine receptor - and without it
You will probably prefer to sit pixels, and do less activity than these
Who work their gene well
If, in fact, your desire for activity and exercise may not be yours. But for many environmental factors
Which means you are not doomed to lazy, but the change may be harder on some of others
Knowledge is strong, if you think you're a lazy genie
Stand up on the couch and fight the DNA that hinders you from activity and will reward you for that
Need help with this? Check out the previous Video Productivity flag
Which may help you improve your motivation and fight laziness
And if you want to learn more about the science of outstanding athletes
One of our favorite books is "Jane the Sport" by David Epstein
Which was one of our sources in this episode
And you get it from this link
And buy with us for more educational video